[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'hebdo
votre émission qui revient sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 29 mai malgré
le plan de 8 milliards d'euros annoncé
par le gouvernement pour l'ensemble du
secteur automobile l'entreprise au
losange renault prévoit pas moins de
4500 suppressions de postes en france
nous ferons le point en ce qui concerne
les trois sites vive les noix le premier
ministre edouard philippe a annoncé
légine de la deuxième étape de
déconfinement et parmi elles la
réouverture des bars et restaurants en
zones ouvertes de leur terrasse
seulement pour la zone orange donc fait
partie des yvelines nous entrerons à ce
sujet un représentant du secteur de la
restauration
le festival et hall factory qui se
prépare pour septembre aux implants
sport santé culture civisme pour
accompagner la réouverture progressive
des écoles et les maires élus au premier
installé nous reviendrons sur ce qui a
marqué la semaine dans votre département
le groupe renault a présenté ce vendredi
29 mai son plan d'économies sur trois
ans une réduction des coûts de 2
milliards d'euros dont les activités
d'ingénierie de production et des
fonctions support près de 4600 postes
vont être supprimés en france les trois
sites du conducteur automobile basée
dans les yvelines sont concernés par ce
programme
les explications de nicolas landry
et si les yvelines devenait le pôle
d'innovation de renault avec le plan
d'économies présenté par la direction le
programme prévoit deux milliards
d'économies notamment une réduction de
800 millions d'euros des coûts sur
l'ingénierie
objectif réduire la diversité des
véhicules tout en concentrant le
développement des technologies à haute
valeur ajoutée sur les sites d'île de
france notamment au technocentre de
guyancourt où sur le site de villiers
saint frédéric
ce que nous voulons faire de la france
c'est vraiment le coeur de notre
ingénierie
alors effectivement il peut y avoir
quelques petits mouvements d'effectifs
sur sur la france parce que nous
utilisons au mieux notre réseau mondial
mais surtout nous allons concentrer en
france toutes les technologies de pointe
et à forte valeur ajoutée nous
refermerons qu'un seul site à l'horizon
2022 sur nos 14 sites industriels en
france s'est choisie pour lequel nous
allons valoriser les compétences en
région parisienne avec le transfert des
activités de choisy-le-roi l' usine de
flins transformerait son activité de
production en un centre dédié à
l'économie circulaire toutes les
activités sont concernées par la
réduction des effectifs près de 4600
postes sont concernés en france par des
mesures de reconversion ou de départs
volontaires
les avis sont partagés du côté des
syndicats c'est un plan d'économies qui
a que pour ambition de réduire les
capacités de renault à répondre aux
demandes des populations
mais cette activité autour de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'économie circulaire
ne fera pas une activité suffisante pour
le personnel c'est à millimes en mille
suppressions d'emplois sur le site de
flins partir de maintenant on va
entendre une pale de négociations aussi
travaillé avec la direction pour
comprendre les tenants et les
aboutissants et ceux et surtout plus
pratique le plus important c'est clair
qu'on se dirige
et à quoi peut ressembler à renault en
2023/2024 un seul que ce soit dans les
biens qu'on ait cette vision là autre
conséquence de ce plan d'économies le
programme e tc art de rénovation du
technocentre de guyancourt pourrait être
revu et re est étudié pour réduire les
coûts un nouveau décès en 24 heures au
décompte dus
fumer portant à 490 le nombre de morts
dus coronavirus à l'hôpital dans les
yvelines depuis le début de la crise les
hospitalisations sont quant à elles
toujours en baisse avec huit personnes
de moins un chiffre à la hausse celui
des retours à domicile 17 personnes
supplémentaires ont pu sortir de
l'hôpital
ils sont 1887 au total
[Musique]
depuis le 15 mars les bars et
restaurants français sont fermés pour
aider à la lutte contre le colonel virus
les restaurateurs qui ont appris la
nouvelle en plein service pour une
fermeture le soir même on enfin une date
de réouverture ce sera le 2 juin pour
les yvelines si tu es encore en zone
orange à dutil ans particulière seuls
les terrasses pourront accueillir du des
clients à cette date
pour le reste il faudra attendre le
prochain point du gouvernement le 22
juin
nous sommes en cause en communication
avec césar molina vous êtes représentant
illinois du groupement national des
indépendants de l'hôtellerie et la
restauration
vous-même restaurateur à vercel bonjour
bonjour
alors tout d'abord comment avez vous
vécu cette période
d'une manière assez particulière je fais
difficile nous nous avons quatre
restaurants sur la place du manège
versailles pendant la période de saison
le fonctionnement est pratiquement 50%
d'une clientèle touristique que nous
l'avons pas eu cette année j'ai
tellement et que nous n'aurons pas et
une manières dans l'immédiat nous allons
garder la pizzeria avec la partie et
livraison ils rentrent emporté à taller
denis virot et puis à travers des gens
qui venaient chercher ça directement
ça nous a permis d'avoir une petite
activité est conservé trois emplois pour
les restes et tous les autres
restaurants étaient fermés et concernant
un peu la situation dans les yvelines
vos confrères ce que vous avez des
retours sur la façon disons que sa
religion et politique
le cas dans le même cas par exemple je
dirais que nous avons juste à côté a
noté nevis qui a fermé ses portes et
partout ces périodes et qui ouvrira les
deux les deux ans ça va ouvrir l'hôtel
de lui qu'il est juste au dessus quitte
à 4 étoiles fait partie du groupe accor
et jean fermer complètement et pour
l'instant il s'apparente pas ouvrir les
non-dits en tout cas pas avant mi
juillet aussi et après ensuite la
restauration géo versailles jantes plein
plein de jolies restaurant mais qu'une
rupture face des petites tailles et ces
gens là gentiment bon tout le monde a
été impactée par ce pendant ces périodes
de fermeture et même lors de l'ouverture
ils ont été apportées puisqu'ils vont
réduire leurs activités à la moitié
pratiquement puisque pour paresser voir
pour l'instant une journée toute petite
terrasse la mairie a bien réagi et la
corée à une autorisation d c'est aller
un petit plus à l'extérieur sur les sur
l'accès public ce qui est une bonne
chose mais en partie du vent des cantons
va ouvrir les places en intérieur s'est
montré limité donc et ça va
automatiquement les différents chiffres
d'affaires quand il écrivit limiter les
chiffres et la fille est ce qu'on pourra
conserver tous les emplois qu'on a en ce
moment c'est pas cette chance est-ce que
tout de même vous êtes soulagés par
cette annonce n'était pas forcément
attendu un problème pour les lits de
france voilà c'était attendu et par les
restaurateurs
j'ai tiré par les clients moi j'ai déjà
eu trois personnes qui sont passées
c'est ma table pour réserver des places
en terrasse pour dimanche prochain
ce dimanche donc je préférerais mais
pour le dimanche après qu'il a fait des
mers donc effectivement les gens
réagissent favorablement et il atteint
des pics à ses voix en plus alors il va
quand même falloir respecter quelques
règles
avec les distanciation social en mètres
entre chaque table est de maximum 10
personnes le port du masque pour le
obligatoire pour le personnel comment
vous avez envisagé vous tout cela je ne
dois pas je n'avais pas ça ne va pas
être une zone 30 et jusqu'à devenir le
port du masque nous au niveau des
plaignants dans leur entend porter les
personnels des pizzaïolos la paix
chantier de cuisine a personne qui est
au service entre les à masquer s'arrête
et peut-être un peu plus compliqué pour
les clients venaient faire respecter
effectivement les pros du masque les
gains qui seront en terrasse pour
l'enlever
par contre les gens qui viendront par
exemple aux toilettes dans les
restaurants il faudra qu'il est maître
pour un toilette
nous on a déjà prévu effectivement un
passage assez large des points des gels
à l'entrée des toilettes et la sortie
accentuer un peu la partie sanitaire à
l'intérieur donc vraiment adapté à cette
partie à cette période qui va être
vraiment karim particulière et donc pas
de plexiglas comme vous pouvez le voir
des restaurateurs qui en amont préparer
déjà les choses à celle de plexi au
niveau de la classe mais ceci dit nous
on va éviter que les gens bien payés en
cash pour parler directement les
éditions à table pour l'écrire départ
entre et restaurants on a pris on a deux
ans le fait de porter d'entraidé sur qui
donc d'un côté les clients paieront d'un
côté pour aller aux toilettes pour
chanter de l'autre côté on va faire un
circuit intérieur où ils se croiseront
pas donc ça permet des films art de
faciliter les choses et les respecter la
liste des licences surtout au niveau des
yvelines parce qu'il ya quand même cette
contrainte de n'ouvrir que enterrait ce
qu'est ce que vous savez s'il ya
beaucoup de restaurants qui sont
concernés qui eux ne pourront pas ouvrir
tout de suite je pense qu'il ya
énormément des restaurants qui ne
pourront pas ouvrir tout de suite jean
par exemple sur la place de marché avec
ça il ya plein de jolies restera mais
vers les fixes surface qui ont des
terrasses mais qu'ils n'échouent pas
énorme
bon la mairie a donné jeudi dans les
accords pour qu'il puisse agrandir
l'extérieur mais sa validité quand même
les nombreux déplacés sera limité
l'activité automatiquement en plus de
passionnés la cuisine touché c'est pas
être la grande cuisine on voit pas
pouvoir avoir trois quarts des personnes
à travailler ensemble
donc j'ai récupéré match délicate c'est
vrai que vous dépendez on peut aussi du
sort des mairies qui accepteront nous
détendre les terrasses est ce que le
groupement national d'internautes par
exemple qu'on peut faire quoi pour
demander ces autorisations la complétant
je trouve que les génies a très bien
réagi ce sont bien occupés de cette
partie là je veux tout en essayant de
négocier et tout ce qui était révision
des loyers tout ce qui est déjà la
chaîne dédiée au moins pendant trois
mois mais en temps de voir les
assurances pour voir si on arrive à
avoir un minimum des remboursements aux
livres la place l'exploitation la mairie
à versailles a très bien réagi aussi
réussi un temps été enterré par exemple
est bon de donner un carton des
marathons des masques sacrés choix donc
qui sont donnés par les marchés je ne
parle pas paraître général parlait en
région donc parce que la mairie a
facilité les choses
pendant cette période
la mairie a fait à la gratuité des
loyers pour tous les locaux qui
appartenait à la mairie de confinement
non ils ont vraiment je dirais
formidable avec les les restaurateurs et
avec des commerçants général et qu'est
ce que vous attendez pour la suite donc
on à cette date du 22 juin pour
peut-être une réouverture à l'intérieur
parce que j'imagine que parfois vrai la
terrasse a fait permet pas de faire tout
son chiffre d'affaires surtout quand
j'étais déjà intéressé à une clientèle
et leur chiffre d'affaires mais c'est
chez lui il va il va y avoir des jours
de pluie où les gens ne pourront pas
rangé à terrace qu'il faudrait bien
prochainement atterrir donc à
l'intérieur on va voir le nombre était
utilisé par deux voire par trois donc
leur effectivement moins des clients à
savoir si j'évite si on peut déjà fêter
ma part y est un peu pour nous ça nous
soulage énormément
on attendait ça depuis depuis bien
longtemps ouais merci césar molina 12
est rendu disponible pour répondre à nos
questions que je rappelle vous êtes
restaurateur à versailles et membre du
groupe national des indépendants de
l'hôtellerie et la restauration
et quant aux autres annonces de ce
deuxième plan du déconfinement nous
reviendrons dessus dans cette édition
[Musique]
c'est officiel depuis lundi skywest a
été racheté par la société des grands
magasins le centre commercial de 30
mille mètres carrés où l'on retrouve
plusieurs enseignes de loisirs et de
divertissement est implantée à montigny
le bretonneux incident vendus par la
société hammerson qui reste propriétaire
de l'espace saint quentin centre
commercial attenant
on écoute le directeur des opérations de
la société des grands magasins
interrogés par nicolas landry et ouest
nous a vus par un emplacement on est
dans une zone résidentielle une zone de
riche en activités en bureau en
entreprise donc on a identifié un vrai
potentiel et qui aujourd'hui ne semble
sous-exploité parce que le centile les
remplir un peu plus de la moitié rempli
aux deux tiers et on sait qu'il ya
encore un travail à mener sur ce centre
pour exploiter tout son potentiel et
qu'on va réellement continuer cette
stratégie en s'axant sur le
divertissement sur le loisir et puis
renforcé un petit pot si leur prestation
qui accompagnera est la configuration se
prête parfaitement aux loisirs avec des
grandes cellules disponibles sur les
deux premiers niveaux et pour accélérer
le remplacement du centre est espéré à
horizon 12 à 18 mois
le remplir à 100% on a identifié
quelques acteurs et avec trois ou quatre
acteurs qui prendrait des très grosses
cellules on arrivera à remplir
l'ensemble méchante de nombreux
festivals sont annulés depuis plusieurs
semaines en raison de l'épidémie de
coronavirus à mantes la jolie le hall
factory festival pourrait être le
premier grand rendez vous culturel du
territoire dans les mois à venir
il doit se tenir du 18 au 20 septembre
avec une programmation très éclectique
mélanie poquet trois jours trois scènes
et 20 concerts les chiffres clés pour
profiter d'un coin d'herbe et de musique
pour sa deuxième édition toujours
maintenu pour l'heure le festival est
une factory met en avant son patrimoine
de factures d'instruments ya aussi ce
côté a pas de barrière pas de frontières
entre les styles de musique souvent on
repère un festival par rapport à son
étiquette jazz son étiquette musiques
actuelles ou sur l'étiquette musique
classique nous on a envie de valoriser
le tout de valoriser les musiciens de
valoriser la pratique musicale et donc
et même de favoriser les ponts entre ces
différentes disciplines
grande amatrice de jazz la cantatrice
nathalie de ces relève le
fille d'une création avec le duke
orchestra sont aussi annoncés kassav et
les têtes raides une organisation
possible grâce au nombre de personnes
autorisées
le festival ne vise pas la limite des
cinq mille personnes les équipes
planchent sur plusieurs scénarii
possibles pour l'instant on parle
beaucoup de du du placement des
personnes des distanciation de recours à
certaines pratiques d'hygiène aussi de
nettoyage des différents éléments
on parle aussi de distribution de jali
droit greek pourquoi pas de de masques
etc
enfin tout ce qui est qui fait partie
maman finalement de notre quotidien
le festival pourrait être une double
fête le 20 septembre montrent la jolie
devrait aussi être synonyme du départ de
la dernière étape du tour de france 2020
après avoir applaudi le pô le ton
pourquoi ne pas applaudir les artistes
et lundi nous apprenions également
l'élection de georges siffredi comme
nouveau président des hauts-de-seine
seul candidat il a été élu avec 38 voix
pour les huit membres de l'opposition
n'ayant pas pris part au vote
le maire de châtenay malabry succède à
patrick devedjian décédé le 29 mars
dernier du coït 19
l'ancien premier vice président assuré
d'ailleurs l'intérim à la tête du 92
depuis cette disparition
dans son discours d'investiture georges
siffredi a précisé que son mandat serait
dans la continuité de son prédécesseur
notamment sur la poursuite du projet de
fusion avec les yvelines depuis 2016 les
deux départements ou entamé un
rapprochement avec la mutualisation déjà
de plusieurs services des compétences
un dossier qui tenait à coeur à patrick
devedjian et qui va pouvoir aller de
l'avant
de quoi réjouir le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
le nouveau président forcément peut voir
des choses différemment de ce que george
est assez attachés à cette à ce
rapprochement
mais les difficultés que l'épidémie a
suscité dans nos économies
d'autres
aujourd'hui ce qui est certain c'est que
georges siffredi et moi même sommes dans
l'état d'esprit de gens qui veulent
approfondir la coopération au site de
département parce qu'elle est de notre
point de vue est essentielle pour
l'ouest parisien et plus globalement
d'ailleurs pour la région ça veut dire
que le travail a peut-être déjà repris
leur prend très vite sur son venin
normalement nous voyons vendredi
avec jacques qui a été élu hier
dominique baert attend trop longue
réunion de travail pour faire le point
sur tous nos dossiers et dossier passer
les dossiers présents et à venir
le dispositif de s2 c'est pour sport
santé culture civisme sera lancée à
partir du début du mois de juin dans
plusieurs écoles maternelles et
élémentaires des yvelines un outil
pédagogique adapté à la réouverture
progressive des écoles mardi 26 mai la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
charline avenel et le maire des mureaux
françois gare et ont signé une
convention pour appliquer cette mesure
dans les établissements de la ville
les détails dans ce reportage de
mathilde et demi et nicolas landry ce
qui a des copines qui te manque pièce
que tu aimerais qui reviennent d'accord
nour a fait partie des huit élèves
présents ce mardi 26 mai dans l'école
maternelle pierre brossolette des
mureaux avec le respect des gestes
barrières écriture coloriage et jeux de
construction sont au programme
habituellement ils sont 102 enfants
accueillis chaque jour dans cet
établissement
ce qui est important c'est qu'il
retrouve les les personnes de l'école
qu'il retrouve les enseignants qui leur
trouvent les pratiques pédagogiques
qu'ils avaient et que
ils puissent refaire ce qu'il avait fait
avec leurs parents avec les enseignants
pour faire revenir les élèves et assurer
une continuité pédagogique pour tous
dans les écoles maternelles et primaires
le dispositif deux aces de ces sports
santé et culture civisme a été lancé par
l'état des activités éducatives en
complément du travail scolaire
l'intérêt c'est d'abord du lien du lien
collectif c'est un immense moyens de
ramener les élèves vers l'école ça nous
prépare également à ce qui se passera
pendant les vacances parce qu'on ne va
pas laisser les élèves et les jeunes et
les enfants pendant ses vacances sans
contact sans activité et sans vacances
apprenant puisque nous y travaillons la
commune des mureaux a signé ce
partenariat à partir du 9 juin les
élèves de la ville auront deux jours
d'enseignement et deux jours d'ateliers
deux aces de ces avec plusieurs
activités en collaboration avec des
associations de la ville on a une
association qui l'office du
développement durable dont il va
intervenir sur tout ce qui est là liés à
l'environnement notamment la gestion de
l'eau la gestion de la terre et on est
en train de regarder aussi avec des
associations de danse qui ne sont pas
nécessairement dans le centre d heure
d'autres communes comme guyancourt
fontenay-le-fleury poissy et versailles
ont déjà contacté l'académie pour
bénéficier du dispositif activités
essentielles le transport de passagers
n'a jamais cessé même pendant le
confinement
mais depuis le 17 mars de nouvelles
règles sont apparus pour les conducteurs
comme pour les usagers à ski bus le
fonctionnement a été revu mélanie poquet
combinaisons masques et machines
philippe va passer les prochaines
minutes à désinfecter en plus dont le
service est terminée il pulvérise un
virus il dans une cinquantaine de
véhicules chaque jour du haut vers le
bas puisque sa sécession si pulvérisé
donc de fines particules de produits de
façon à ce que ce dernier repose sur
les chaises affalé dossier toutes les
rentes maintient que pourrait utiliser
un passager lorsque celui ci monte dans
le car c'est un produit qui est tenu
d'être efficace pendant 24 heures
et ainsi de suite une désinfection jusqu
alors inédite les transporteurs
yvelinois s'y sont mis dès l'apparition
de l'épidémie ski bus le complète avec
des gestes barrières la mobilisation est
associé avec un nettoyage manuel jusqu'à
la semaine dernière ont monté par la
porte arrière et on descendait par les
portes arrière et depuis ce matin on a
remis une circulation normale dans le
véhicule au monde par la porte avant et
on descend par les portes arrière et on
a condamné un siège sur deux pour faire
respecter la distanciation nécessaire et
on a indiqué au sol aussi par le moyen
de petits stickers les espaces
un maître pour que chacun puisse avoir
une indication elle la capacité des
véhicules est réduite à une vingtaine de
places 6 qui bus maintient aujourd'hui
95% de son offre la fréquentation n'est
toujours pas revenu à la normale
seulement 25 % des usagers ont repris le
chemin des transports en commun depuis
le déconfinement la demande de dépistage
du cours d'un virus par voie nasale a
augmenté pourtant le nombre de personnes
positives diminue dans le laboratoire de
montigny le bretonneux ou des tests sont
effectués
nous vous faisions découvrir cela
mercredi manon par aldo et aurélien 11 à
16 heures le laboratoire ferme ses
portes pour accueillir les personnes
présentant des symptômes évocateurs du
coc vide 19 et ainsi éviter le contact
avec la patiente est l'habituel ces
personnes peuvent bénéficier d'un
dépistage par test pcr par voie nasale
le test est assez rapide en soi puisque
certains prélèvements dans les deux
narines on introduit un écouvillon à ses
fins jusqu'au nasopharynx donc ça va
assez loin
et voilà donc le test dure quelques
minutes chaque jour une vingtaine de
personnes est testé dans ce laboratoire
de retour d'un séjour à l'étranger cette
patiente souffre d'une dégradation de
son état respiratoire
j'ai fait un voyage en république
dominicaine au mois de mars et les
premiers signes de pas dire de tout son
arrivée à mon retour pour effectuer le
dépistage du coronavirus il ne faut en
aucun cas se rendre directement dans le
laboratoire de biologie
le rendez vous se prend au préalable par
email afin d'éviter et tous documents
susceptibles d'être contaminés
en arrière le virus peut donner une
palette de symptômes très variés les
enveloppes sont pas vraiment reconnue
comme un symptôme courant mais c'est les
personnes jeunes c'était pas mal observé
par les dermatos même si c'est pas
garantie à côté de ça c'était un peu de
mal de tête un peu de température les
personnes identifiées comme cas contacts
peuvent également se faire dépister
c'est le cas de cette mère de famille
fièvre vomissements courbatures le test
est facile à effectuer non invasif mais
désagréable pour le patient car un peu
douloureux
les résultats sont communiqués dans les
24 heures en attendant le médecin
préconise de rester à son domicile jeudi
le gouvernement présentait la phase 2 du
déconfinement réouverture des bars et
restaurants comme on l'a dit mais aussi
règle des 100 km or il renonce fait le
pont pour vous l'épidémie de e.coli 19
ralenti les résultats sont bons sur le
plan sanitaire conséquence il n'y a
désormais plus de départements en rouge
sur la carte de france
seul notre région l'île de france et en
orange
alors première bonne nouvelle et bien
dès ce week-end le public pourra de
nouveau accéder aux parcs et aux jardins
franciliens concernant vos déplacements
dès le 2 juin la règle des 100 km est
supprimée sur le territoire français
dans le secteur de l'éducation
maintenant 100% des écoles maternelles
et primaires ouvriront progressivement
dès mardi 2 juin l'ensemble des collèges
va rouvrir y compris dans les yvelines
qui est donc en zone orange avec dans un
premier temps elle les sixièmes et les
cinquièmes pour les lycées yvelinois la
priorité sera donnée aux établissements
professionnels et notamment aux élèves
qui doivent passer une certification
pour les lycées généraux il y aura des
convocations individuelles
enfin informations importantes l'épreuve
orale du bac de français est annulé elle
sera validée en contrôle continu
concernant maintenant elle les bars les
cafés les restaurants ils pourront
rouvrir en zone verte et les yvelines et
en zone orange seuls les terrasses
seront autorisés à rouvrir dès le
2 juin le 2 juin tous les musées et
monuments ouvriront également sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour les parcs
de loisirs les salles de spectacle et
les piscines ou encore les salles de
théâtre et bien il faudra attendre le 22
juin dans les yvelines pour qu'il rouvre
les cinémas heureux ouvriront leurs
portes le 22 juin
mais ça ce sera sur l'ensemble du
territoire même date également 22 juin
pour l'ouverture des campings yvelinois
reste interdit les événements culturels
et sportifs dans l'espace public
l'ouverture des discothèques les stades
les hippodromes ou encore les salles de
jeux enfin un nouveau point sera fait
justement aux alentours du 22 juin pour
la phase iii du déconfinement c'est sans
doute l'une des conséquences directes de
la crise sanitaire et du confinement qui
en a résulté
le nombre de chômeurs a augmenté
considérablement en avril + 17 % dans
les yvelines en un mois pour la
catégorie a au score sensiblement sur la
même tendance qu'au niveau national
l'augmentation est de 22 6% toutes
catégories confondues les élus n'ont
jamais compté autant de demandeurs
d'emploi depuis 1996 ils étaient cent
ans mais 540 le mois dernier ils ont dû
patienter deux mois après leur élection
pour s'installer enfin les conseils
municipaux élus au premier tour on peut
désigner leurs maires et adjoints tous
dans des conditions particulières et
parfois des lieux inattendus pour
respecter les mesures de distanciation
physique montigny le bretonneux s'y est
mis dès le samedi 23 mai et a choisi la
ferme du manet la tête de liste issue de
la majorité sortante laura merckaert a
été élu samedi également pour mort par
grégory gars ici a été reconduit lors
d'un conseil d'installation dans le
gymnase de la malle me donne lundi soir
c'était au tour de coignières à la
maison de voisinage
didier fischer qui avait été désigné en
décembre 2018 suite à la démission de
jean-pierre sevestre a été réélu par son
conseil municipal celui de saint cyr
l'école s'est réunie ce même jour au
théâtre gérard philipe sonia bros a été
élu pour un deuxième mandat
enfin elancourt le conseil municipal
d'installation s'est tenue le mercredi à
l'hôtel de ville une séance retransmise
en direct sur le site internet de la
ville
dix adjoints ont été désignés autour du
maire et
jean michel fourgous des élections
municipales qui ont été abordés dans le
dernier club de la presse l'émission on
comprend vos différents médias locaux et
à retrouver ce week-end sur notre
antenne le cette ut hebdo touche à sa
fin merci de nous avoir suivis retour de
l'actualité locale et l'un des poumons
week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]